MALE SPEAKER: Good afternoon.
Welcome to Musicians at Google
in Cambridge, Massachusetts.
Please silence all cellphones,
real cutlery, anything
that could make any noise.
Thanks to David Flores, we
have a remarkable event today.
I am here to introduce Brad
from Thinksay Records, who
are releasing David Duchovny's
solo-- not solo album,
it's recorded with a band.
Sorry.
First mistake already.
He's chuckling.
David Duchovny's new
album, "Hell or Highwater."
We are the second audience
who will be hearing anything
from this album.
He's going to be playing
more from it tonight
at Berkeley School of Music,
but they have to wait for us.
So without further ado, let me
introduce Brad from Thinksay
who's going to say some more.
[APPLAUSE]
BRAD: So I'm Brad
from Thinksay Records.
We are located right here
in Boston, Massachusetts.
And we are here today to
introduce David Duchovny.
We want to thank him for
coming out here today--
that'll be good,
thanks-- giving his time.
We're a small
independent record label
and we put out maybe like
one to three records a year.
And through a mutual
friend over a year
ago I was introduced to
David and he played me
some of the songs that he wrote.
And I really loved them.
I thought the melodies
were really cool,
and I thought lyrically
they were just like, wow.
You could be a musician.
And then we just
started talking,
and we kind of vibed over
the same sort of stuff.
And it became a
real project for me.
The journey of
making this record
was something when I
was in summer camp,
and with Dave Flores, who
I was at summer camp with.
And we would just listen to
records over and over again.
And you'd be like,
oh, some day we're
going to be in the
studio, and we're
going to be making records.
And that never, ever
happens, until, you know,
I worked at Sony
Music for 20 years
and I worked with
everybody from Beyonce
to Johnny Cash to John Mayer.
And it never happened until
this project came along
that was just so niche and so
cool and so left of center.
And I just entered on a
real journey with David
and with everybody at
Thinksay and everybody
on his team to make this record.
And it just became that
project that you dream about.
That was something I 100% did
for the journey and the ride.
And the business end,
we'll make some money.
We'll lose some money.
We don't know exactly what's
going to happen there--
hopefully make some money.
But if not, we'll be
sleeping on David's couch.
And you know, it's still
nicer than my house.
The point is, it's one
of those dream projects.
It's like, if there's something
you're passionate about-- I was
passionate about R.E.M. and
The Smiths and Lou Reed and Bob
Dylan.
And for me, those are my heroes.
And then when you see reviews in
"Rolling Stone" about the album
that's coming out and it says,
sounds like The Cure and R.E.M.
and Lou Reed and Bob Dylan,
and you're like, wow,
this is trippy.
So kind of like the guy
probably that started Google,
but he made like
a ton more money.
He had an idea, and that
really panned out well
for a lot of people.
So anyways, I want
to introduce David.
We're going to play a song.
We're going to play four
tracks off the record
and then in between, I'm going
to ask a couple questions,
and we're going to hand
it over to you guys
to ask questions to David about
what's going on in his life
and in his career.
So I just want to thank
quickly the people that
really helped do this.
David Flores, Kathleen, Carrie
Lee, the band, of course.
But me and my friend
were sitting on the couch
one day watching
"Californication."
I was like, you work at Google.
Maybe I'll come by with David.
Do you think people
would be interested?
And he's like, oh definitely.
I'm like, OK, cool.
So now we're here.
So that's how it happened.
But without further
ado, the people
you really want
to see, the band.
Colin Lee, Pat McCusker,
and David Duchovny.
[APPLAUSE]
DAVID DUCHOVNY: Hi.
I have this USB thing
that goes in the--
[LAUGHTER]
Yeah.
So these are the stripped down
versions of songs on the album.
I guess we call them acoustic,
but we seem to be amplified.
So it's kind of an in between.
But what are we going
to start with? "3000"?
It has some New York
geography-- I apologize
for that-- in this song.
There's a lot of Central
Park imagery, so forgive me.
[MUSIC - DAVID DUCHOVNY, "3000"]
[APPLAUSE]
BRAD: So, it sounded great.
It's the second time you've ever
performed in front of people.
DAVID DUCHOVNY:
That's the happy song.
BRAD: Yeah.
[LAUGHTER]
So it's been definitely
a busy year for you,
and being part of making
this record was interesting
because it was the first time
I made an album with-- I don't
want to say someone like David.
He's sort of a
unique guy in is own,
but somebody that's had massive
success on the Hollywood side.
DAVID DUCHOVNY:
Where'd my band go?
BRAD: They're done.
They left.
DAVID DUCHOVNY: What the hell?
BRAD: One song.
DAVID DUCHOVNY: Stay out here.
We're going to sing some more.
BRAD: Yeah, Yeah.
DAVID DUCHOVNY: Yeah.
BRAD: We have
questions for you too.
So trying to just schedule
and make this all happen
was a little bit longer than
making a traditional record.
But David decided to write a
book in between it all and then
was coming off filming a new
show for NBC called "Aquarius,"
which we'll talk about in a
bit, and "X-Files" coming back,
filming this summer.
So a lot of stuff going on.
And we'll get to that too.
So in terms of writing an
album, it's a very real record.
Can you talk a little
bit about the process
of actually making the music?
Like, how these
songs came to you.
Is this a collection of
thoughts over years of time?
Is it a certain period?
And just taking the jump from
the Hollywood side to say I'm
going to really write songs.
DAVID DUCHOVNY:
Well, it's a-- yeah,
I guess it's a certain period.
All the songs have a certain
kind of flavor to them,
I think.
It's like a snapshot
of a certain time.
But I think I just
never had an idea
that I would make an album.
I have a phone that
records things on it.
You guys might have heard of it.
OK, I won't do jokes
like that so much.
I thought they'd go over
better, but they're not
going over well at all.
Anyway, so I have
Garage Band on my phone.
And I just use it
as a tape recorder
because I can't even figure out
how to do multi-tracks on it.
And I only play one instrument,
so it doesn't matter.
So I would just sit there,
and after I figured out
that there are only so
many chords that you
can play on guitar,
and in rock and roll
there are only so many chords.
And these songs that I like,
And at some point I
knew most of them.
So I thought, well, maybe if
I can come up with a melody,
I can write a song.
So I started doing that.
The words for me
were always first
and always, I don't want
to say easy, but easier.
And so then I just starting
putting words on the melodies
and put them on my phone.
And I thought, oh, I've
written some songs that
are on my phone.
I hope nobody finds my phone.
And then through Keaton
Simons I met Brad.
And Brad really kept
pushing me to get better,
and you know, just to
get better and to get
more serious about recording,
and hooked me up with Colin
and the rest of the guys.
And we made it into an album.
I love the sound of it.
I can't believe
that I'm part of it.
It's the weirdest feeling.
I'm not sure it's real.
But he showed me
the physical box.
You got the box?
BRAD: Carrie, do we
have that somewhere?
[LAUGHTER]
DAVID DUCHOVNY:
Today, this morning
was the first time I saw it
and I was like, give me that.
BRAD: It's probably in my bag.
DAVID DUCHOVNY: I didn't
answer any question,
but I said some things.
BRAD: Yeah.
Well, I think one of the
things that stood out
to me most in this project is--
DAVID DUCHOVNY: Why
isn't it in my bag?
Why is it in that bag?
It should be in my bag.
BRAD: That's only the proof.
It's not even out yet.
I think it's in
the middle pocket.
DAVID DUCHOVNY: For instance,
"Hell or Highwater," which
is the single, Brad loves that
song, and he would not stop.
He's just such a
pain in the ass.
You know, I only have my voice.
You know, it's a
small instrument.
And Brad was like, sing
better, sing better.
And I hated--
BRAD: Not exactly like that.
DAVID DUCHOVNY: No,
he's very encouraging.
No.
That didn't sound-- I sounded
like I was being ironic.
But he's actually
a total enthusiast
and makes a lot
of stuff possible.
He's one of those guys that
tells you it can be done,
which is rare.
Most people tell you it can't.
But even so, he was a real pain
in the ass about that song.
And we finally got
it last winter.
Look at that thing.
BRAD: Tell them about
the album cover.
DAVID DUCHOVNY:
It's upside down.
[APPLAUSE]
Anyway, so more--
BRAD: Tell them about
the album cover.
DAVID DUCHOVNY: There's
a camera on my phone.
And I took that picture.
I was down vacationing
with my kids
and it's just a reflection.
I was taking a picture of them.
You can't see them.
They're in the room,
and you only see me.
But it's not important.
[LAUGHTER]
BRAD: I think the import
part of the picture
of that is we would often
practice in David's living
room.
And then through the
months and months,
you're thinking
about art and how
you want to market the
record, and et cetera.
And I always love kind of
the black and white imagery,
we all kind of did.
And then coming up with the
album cover took forever,
and finally we were like,
wait, this picture that's
been hanging above us while
we've been making this album,
let's just use that.
And that's how it came together.
DAVID DUCHOVNY: And it was
cheap because I took it.
BRAD: And it was cheap.
Yeah, exactly.
OK, let's hear another song.
DAVID DUCHOVNY: This is
called "Let it Rain."
There's a lot of
rain on the album.
[MUSIC DAVID DUCHOVNY, "LET IT
RAIN"]
[APPLAUSE]
BRAD: That sounds great.
Like David said, I'm
a bit of a miser when
it comes to the sound, so
when it sounds perfect,
I'm that one weird guy that's
like, no, one more time.
And then that's like six
hours later, you're like,
OK, we got it.
DAVID DUCHOVNY: You want
me to sing it again, right?
BRAD: Yeah, exactly.
But I remember we were in the
studio and starting, and Colin
Lee here, who is the
producer of the record, Colin
and I met through
one of the girls who
works with me, Carrie.
That's Carrie's brother.
And he's been a musician in
his own band called Weather.
And I really thought he'd
be a great match with David
to help bring out the ideas.
And I remember it was like
the first day in the studio,
and it was like the first
line of the first song.
We're like, OK, take one.
And then it was like 100
versions of the line,
and then Colin
came in the studio
and David couldn't
hear us, so he
was just seeing like me, Carrie,
and Colin, like-- you know?
And then he was like, is
everything cool in there?
We're like, yeah.
We're just listening to an edit.
Yeah.
Everything's cool.
And then Colin was like, we're
going to be here all day.
Do you know how long
this is going to take?
Santa's not going to be happy.
The toys have got to get out.
DAVID DUCHOVNY:
I don't know if I
should be here for this story.
It's the first I've heard of it.
BRAD: Yeah, well, now you--
DAVID DUCHOVNY: I
will show you what
I looked like at the end
of four hours of trying
to sing one song.
BRAD: Exactly.
So the first day
was a little rough,
as you see the way
David wound up,
because this is a new process
for all of us doing this.
And it was interesting because
the first day, I think,
we got through not as much.
DAVID DUCHOVNY: One song.
One song.
BRAD: Yeah, one song.
But then the next day
within the morning alone,
we did like three
songs in three hours.
So David really put in a lot of
time and work into the music,
into the vocals.
And to hear it even now,
like the second time
you're playing it,
it's really amazing.
It's a job well done.
DAVID DUCHOVNY: Thank you.
BRAD: One thing I wanted to ask
that I think was special to me
through the project and I
always try to teach the younger
kids that are now working for
my company is taking shots
in life.
My philosophy is,
take shots, pay bills.
So if you can pay your bills
and take shots, you're good.
And that's what I do in my life.
But David, for
somebody who's had
a lot of success in two
different Golden Globe
performances for two
different major characters,
this year you really
did venture out.
You wrote your first book
called "Holy Cow," which
was recently out and a "New
York Times" best seller,
and this album.
I thought maybe you'd
talk a little bit
about taking shots
and trying new things
at this point in your career.
DAVID DUCHOVNY: Oh.
I think that when
I talk to my kids,
I always talk to
them about failing.
And And I was lying
in bed this morning,
I was trying to come
up with a pithy thing.
And I'm going to
try it out on you.
I'm going to try and make
it into "Bartlett's" today.
So success is a lecturer.
Failure is a teacher.
Anybody?
Not bad?
[APPLAUSE]
"Barlett's"?
I don't like the word
lecturer, it's clunky.
But anyway, that's
the way I feel.
It's like, you don't
really learn from success.
You learn maybe intellectually.
But failure teaches you how
to be human being and an adult
and a person and
empathetic and human.
And so I always try to teach my
kids to be comfortable failing.
Not comfortable,
that's the wrong word,
but I think you
know what I mean.
So in taking my shots, I
just feel like, well, all
I can do is fail and that's
like the worst that can happen.
So what?
So then I can try
something else,
or try it again, or whatever.
And I'm lucky enough to
have had success in one area
where the failure doesn't
seem as dire like if I were
to fail doing other things.
So I might be full
of shit because it's
a bit of a safety net.
In fact, I am full of shit.
Anyway.
BRAD: I mean, I think creatively
putting yourself out there
in other arenas, there's
certainly a real risk factor.
It might not be if
the book didn't--
DAVID DUCHOVNY: People
are going to make fun.
People make fun, whatever.
BRAD: Haters gonna hate.
[LAUGHTER]
You know?
DAVID DUCHOVNY: Hit it.
[LAUGHTER]
BRAD: I wanted to talk
about one more thing.
We're going to go
to another song
and then when we
come back, I'm going
to hand it over to
questions from you guys.
"Hell or Highwater"
is out May 12,
and you can watch David perform
on the "Today Show" May 12,
or "Live with Kelly"
on May 14, and tonight
at the 939 Cafe in Boston,
which is at Berkeley.
And all the members of the
band are Berkeley members,
which is how we kind of put
this whole thing together.
But after that, he
takes like, a day off
and then your new show
"Aquarius" airs on NBC.
Why don't you give
them a little bit
of what the show is all about.
It's May 28th, and
it's the first time,
which I think is really
interesting, is "X-Files"
is the longest running
sci-fi show in television.
"Aquarius," which
NBC is releasing
full streaming of the
entire first season,
and this is the first time a
major network is doing that.
I think it's kind of cool to be
in the history books both times
there.
But tell us a little
bit about the show.
DAVID DUCHOVNY: Just
quickly, I'll tell you.
I play a homicide
detective in 1967 in LA.
And the love of my
life, who's gone off
to marry a lawyer who is trying
to get Ronald Reagan elected
governor at the
time, their daughter
disappears, a
15-year-old girl who
runs away with a
bunch of hippies
to go live in the desert.
And she's 15 years old, so
she wants her daughter back
and doesn't want any
notoriety because her husband
and the family is a
big right-wing power.
So she calls me, her old
love, to go find her daughter,
and I track her down.
She's living in the desert with
a fellow named Charlie Manson.
So that's the
beginning of the story.
And that's two years before
the Tate, LaBianca murders,
so he's just kind
of a conman pimp.
You know, not a big deal.
The name doesn't
ring anybody's bell.
And that's how we start.
BRAD: Cool.
All right, let's
hear another song.
[MUSIC DAVID DUCHOVNY, "WHEN THE
TIME COMES"]
[APPLAUSE]
BRAD: So we're going to open up
some questions to the audience.
Carrie back there
has the live mic,
so if there's somebody that
has a question for David
wants to raise their hand.
And just to let you know,
David after "Aquarius"
is going to be filming
this summer six episodes
of "X-Files," which I'm
sure some of you know.
And there's no script
yet that he has in hand.
DAVID DUCHOVNY:
"X-Files" created Google.
BRAD: What's that?
[LAUGHTER]
"X-Files" created Google.
Everybody knows that.
BRAD: That's what
he's doing next.
You can tell, from book,
to show, to album, to show,
it's pretty busy,
so it's exciting.
You're a good guy.
Just want to let them know.
So we'll open it
up to the audience.
AUDIENCE: Hello.
BRAD: If you want to just
say what your name is.
AUDIENCE: Sorry.
My name's Anna Cosmus.
DAVID DUCHOVNY: Hi.
AUDIENCE: Hi.
I was thinking we can't have
a celebrity in the house
without a famous group selfie.
So are you ready?
DAVID DUCHOVNY:
How do I do that?
AUDIENCE: I'll come up there.
BRAD: I think we're going
to do that at the end.
Yeah.
I think we're going to
do the group selfie.
DAVID DUCHOVNY: A group selfie?
You mean, like--
BRAD: That's like where
you've got behind you--
DAVID DUCHOVNY:
It's a Google thing.
It's just like a technological
thing I don't get.
BRAD: It's Google.
AUDIENCE: Oh boy, OK.
I'll ask a real question.
DAVID DUCHOVNY: Somebody
said Twitter [INAUDIBLE]
me the other day.
And was like, nah.
I'm done.
[LAUGHTER]
AUDIENCE: I'll ask
a real question.
DAVID DUCHOVNY: Yeah, that's OK.
AUDIENCE: Who was your
muse for this album?
DAVID DUCHOVNY: God.
I don't know.
You I know, just getting
the music together,
hearing the melodies, and then
just putting the words down.
I mean, I like to think that the
songs just stand on their own
and they-- I don't
really like songs
to be explained to me unless
they don't make any sense.
[LAUGHTER]
Because I think songs
are really for the people
that listen to them.
The songs are not for
me at all anymore.
So I would like to
shut up about the songs
and let what was a muse, or
what was I thinking about,
or what does that mean, you
know, let it mean something
to you, if it does.
And if it doesn't, I'm sorry.
But you know, I think
songs are for others.
I hope they are anyway.
AUDIENCE: All right, thanks.
BRAD: I can tell you I'm
up early, David's up early.
So I have two dachshunds.
One's name Tom Brady and
the other, Lord Fenway.
So Lord Fenway is like the queen
of Queens, like, glorious fur
and she thinks she's
like the mayor of Boston.
And she doesn't
move for anybody.
But any time I play
just David's music--
and I would videotape it and
text it to him all the time.
It was like just kind
of a running joke.
You'd play it, she'd be sleeping
at the other end of the house,
and she'd hear it,
walk over a little bit,
and then just sit in front
of the speaker like that.
So I mean, that's
the number one fan
of the music from the beginning.
Every morning.
That's the muse, that
was the muse really.
DAVID DUCHOVNY: I
have a whole set of--
BRAD: Yeah, there's
probably 800 videos.
DAVID DUCHOVNY:
Four-second videos
of the dog just
turning a corner.
[LAUGHTER]
BRAD: So funny.
OK, another question
AUDIENCE: Hi, my name
is Pat Lopeselli.
And my question is, coming from
another creative profession,
the song writing and
album producing experience
was new for you, as
far as craft goes.
What was the funnest thing
about this new craft?
And what was the hardest
thing about this new craft?
DAVID DUCHOVNY:
Well, since I don't
have to record my own guitar
on the album, that would've
been the hardest because
I'm kind of self-taught
with the guitar because one
of ideas for me when I wanted
to start playing guitar
was I didn't want
it to feel like work at all.
So I was like, no lessons.
I don't want lessons.
So that was stupid because
I have really bad habits,
and I can't play the same
thing twice the same way.
So it's not good for me
to ever record, probably.
I'll never be able
to break that habit.
But the hardest part was
just my voice, really.
I mean, I've never
been a singer.
And I've often been
told to stop singing.
[LAUGHTER]
It's true.
And the fact that I'm up
here singing in front of you
is unbelievable to me.
I'm not kidding.
So when I started talking
to Brad about recording,
I found a voice teacher
New York, just by chance,
who was amazing-- is amazing--
a guy named Don Lawrence.
And in 20 minutes he
had me, not singing,
but he had me thinking
about singing in a way
that I'd never thought before.
And it's amazing when you find
a real teacher, just very lucky.
And so I've been just practicing
singing for a year now.
Every day I sing a little bit.
I do my scales.
[LAUGHTER]
DAVID DUCHOVNY: So you know,
that's been the hardest part,
and just committing to
that and trying to sing.
It's not me, but here I
am, subjecting you to it.
[LAUGHTER]
BRAD: We're going to go
with another question
from the back right.
AUDIENCE: Thanks for coming out.
A quick question that you always
ask people who are into music,
what have you been
listening to recently?
Oh, hey, I'm in the light.
What records have you been
listening to recently?
Are there any bands?
We've had a lot of bands
that come out of Boston.
And just wanted to know what's
been inspiring you recently.
DAVID DUCHOVNY: I tended not
to listen to music while we've
been doing the
record, only because I
find that if I read
when I'm writing,
I tend to just write
what I'm reading.
And that's illegal.
[LAUGHTER]
So I haven't really
been listening,
but historically, I'm just
like a '60s, '70s guy.
Straight ahead rock and roll,
British invasion, Beatles,
Stones, Who, Zeppelin.
But then I go to Tom Petty,
and I love Dylan and Wilco.
R.E.M I love.
I love a lot of
different kinds of music.
BRAD: Your kids, you know
all the modern stuff too.
Like, we were
hanging out yesterday
and you were like this
is Arctic Monkeys.
I love this band.
And I was like, what?
DAVID DUCHOVNY: Yeah, I'm hip.
I'm hip.
[LAUGHTER]
I like Electric Field by MGMT.
How old is that?
It's already old, right?
But I like it.
You don't know it?
Yeah, you know it.
That's good groove, right?
Next time.
Next time, we'll do that.
BRAD: Another question.
Here we go, on the left.
I think she's going
to bring the mic over.
AUDIENCE: Oh, I'm Ed.
DAVID DUCHOVNY: Hi Ed.
AUDIENCE: I was listening to
the lyrics on your first song
that you played and
I was wondering,
do you wear a Fitbit?
[LAUGHTER]
Just because we have a
step competition here.
So.
Yeah.
[LAUGHTER]
DAVID DUCHOVNY: I'm
going to go out on a limb
and say only at Google will I
be asked that question, I hope.
It's funny because
just last weekend I
made the journey of which
I was writing about.
And I was like, I'm
going to count the steps.
And I kept on getting lost.
I had hundreds on my fingers.
I do not have Fitbit.
So I'm so old school.
As they said in
Larry Sanders, they
tore down my school to
build the old school.
So I was like 100,
400, 500, 1,000.
It was about, it was in
the neighborhood of 3,000.
It might have been
a little less.
[LAUGHTER]
But the chorus doesn't
sound as good as 2,796.
2,796.
BRAD: I think we have
another one up here.
AUDIENCE: Hi, I'm Bertha.
I'm also writing
music right now.
So what's your music
writing process?
DAVID DUCHOVNY: It was
just whenever it happened.
I mean, I'd sit down, and
I'd start playing the guitar.
And I would have like
three or four chords
that I liked the way
they fit together.
And then and then
I would just maybe
hear a melody on top of that.
And then the words
were just easy.
I mean, I had a booklet of
thoughts more than words.
And that's it, just kind
all at the same time
rather than one
before the other.
But I would say the chords
and the melody first.
And then lyrically, I never
worry about the lyrics coming.
It was really, will I ever
think of another melody?
And I'm not sure.
BRAD: There's one up front.
DAVID DUCHOVNY: A ringer.
We have a ringer in the house.
Full disclosure
before the question.
Full disclosure.
AUDIENCE: Full disclosure.
We're related.
So how do your kids
feel about Dad suddenly
becoming a rock star?
DAVID DUCHOVNY:
They're embarrassed.
Yeah, they're like
making believe
it's not happening at all.
I'm sure they are.
I mean, they have not
asked to hear anything.
And I do have a concert.
We have the album release
concert next week in New York,
and I've not invited them.
It's late.
It's past their bedtime.
It's funny.
I can only think
and hope that they
get exactly what I wanted
them to get out of it, which
was just like, just try things.
I think, because they would
do-- play a little something.
This is how they react to it.
[LAUGHTER]
So that's what I get from them.
BRAD: It is funny,
because sometimes we'd
play at your house.
It's like 100% music.
And then when your kids
come home, it's 0% music.
It's like we don't talk
about it in front of them.
It's its own entity.
DAVID DUCHOVNY:
It's a dirty secret.
BRAD: Yeah.
We have one more
question, then will do--
DAVID DUCHOVNY: I do have
one song that's specifically
for West called
"Stay on the Train"
that we won't be doing here.
BRAD: You're not
going to play at all?
DAVID DUCHOVNY:
Unless you want to.
BRAD: No, I think we
should do "Hell" maybe.
DAVID DUCHOVNY: Oh,
you want to do "Hell"?
OK.
BRAD: But lets see
if we can do one more
question, or a final question,
before the last song.
Right up front here
on the right, or both.
We'll do two more.
AUDIENCE: Thank you.
Hi, I'm Libby.
DAVID DUCHOVNY: Can I
get a Fitbit for free?
Can I get one for free?
If you show me how to use it.
Where do I put it?
On my foot?
[LAUGHTER]
On your belt.
BRAD: You've got to
Google this stuff, man.
DAVID DUCHOVNY:
How does it know?
That's incredible.
I want a Fitbit.
Huh?
All hell's breaking loose now.
All right.
Where?
BRAD: OK, we'll go to the
last question and then
the final song.
AUDIENCE: I'm Libby.
I don't have a Fitbit.
And so being a creative
person-- acting,
and writing, and
now doing music--
is there one, at this
particular moment,
I'm sure that the singing
is, but is there one
that you're surprised or
that really kind of fills
your soul in a way that you
didn't really expect it to?
DAVID DUCHOVNY: No.
I think they all do something.
I mean, I feel like
just an expressive
person, like I'm just
trying to express something.
And I'm having an image
right now of the cake thing
when you squeeze the icing,
and it's different size nozzle
sometimes.
So that's gross.
[LAUGHTER]
So I guess that's the
way I feel I feel about.
I just try to stay
creative, and try
to stay-- whoa-- try to
stay alive and growing
and challenged.
And challenged, I
try to be challenged.
You know, someone was asking me
yesterday, challenging myself.
And I was like,
well, maybe it would
be nice to not be challenged.
Maybe it would be nice to
just relax a little bit.
But apparently that's
not what I'm into.
So that's all.
I don't know.
I love directing too.
I haven't done much
of that recently.
I like sitting in the
dark yelling instructions.
[LAUGHTER]
BRAD: So this is going to be the
last song, "Hell or Highwater."
And then after the song if
everyone wants to stay seated,
we'll do the group selfie shot.
And thank everybody again.
But this is the single,
"Hell or Highwater."
DAVID DUCHOVNY: Thank you,
and thanks for coming out
and being here, because, really,
this is like rehearsal for us.
So it's great.
Thank you for the
opportunity to rehearse
with your lovely sound system.
[MUSIC DAVID DUCHOVNY, "HELL OR
HIGHWATER"]
[APPLAUSE]
DAVID DUCHOVNY: Thank you.